جماعات حقوق الانسان انتقدت ادوات النظام
الايراني القمعيه الباسيج والحارس الثوري
والجماعات المواليه الاخرى لاستخدامها
العنف ضد المتظاهرين فيما فرضت واشنطن و
بروكسيل ولندن عقوبات على قاده البسيج
لاستخدامهم العنف في اخماد الاحتجاجات
يقول خبير بشؤون بسيج ان ايران تهيئوا
شباب من عائلات محافظه للانضمام اليه الى
البسيج مع تدريب على المبادئ الدينيه
وجهات نظر الحكومه المعاديه للغرب في
معسكرات الاطفال ونوادي الاحياء ويضيف ان
الشباب المواليين يحظون بالاولويه في افضل
الجامعات الايرانيه ما يضعهم في صف
المناصب الحكوميه العليا والوظائف ذات
الاجر الجيد بالشركات التي تسيطر عليها
الفصائل المتشدده
[موسيقى]